Fox News's fake national security expert
story is getting funnier and funnier and
funnier to remind you about this two
weeks ago at a rally Donald Trump
alluded to a swedish terrorist attack
attack never happened then Trump went on
Twitter and said oh I was referring to
something that I got from Fox News Fox
News probably to try to defend Trump and
themselves had a supposed Swedish
national security adviser on The
O'Reilly Factor to talk about the perils
of immigration and the crime it's
causing in Sweden here's a reminder
about this insane interview that Bill
O'Reilly did joining South Washington
Nyles a built or Neil's built I should
say a Swedish defense and national
security adviser D there is a problem
with socially deviant activity there is
a problem with crime there is a problem
with areas or hot spots of crime so that
guy who goes by Nils built but whose
birth name was actually Nils tolling
ended up being a total fake they went
and actually asked real Swedish national
security experts do you know about this
guy and everybody said no we have no
idea who that is we covered that last
week turns out the guy hasn't been in
Sweden for more than 20 years etc etc
that's where we were last week it gets
even better sit down or it gets even
worse depending on who you are built
went on TV to talk about the problem of
violent criminal immigrants in Sweden it
turns out that built is a violent
criminal immigrant to the United States
according to court records from
Arlington Virginia built who again his
last name was tolling until he changed
his last name was convicted of
obstruction to justice obstruction of
justice being drunk in public and
assaulting a police officer all in the
same day in 2004 and we have we did a
search on the Arlington General district
court records website he was sentenced
to a year in jail as you can see in this
second document here ended up serving
only a month bill
denied the charges and the conviction to
a Swedish newspaper but it is all there
in black and white he's at least now
admitted that he's not a Swedish defense
and national security adviser and said
that Fox
News came up with that title all on
their own again hasn't lived in Sweden
for over 20 years moved to the US and 94
owns a security company now what is real
here
Trump's claim about what happened in
Sweden was fake
the idea that Nils built was a Swedish
national security expert was absolutely
and completely fake and it turns out
that the issue he went on to talk about
which is immigrants who come over and
commit crime he is one of those
immigrants who goes to a different
country and commits crimes it just goes
to show that there's always racial
undertones when conservatives talk about
violent immigrants so in the case of
Melania Trump she did work in the United
States illegally in the 1990s as a model
Sylvanian model yeah but no one really
seemed to care because she was in
Hispanic she was an Arab I think it has
to do a lot with the race and the
culture of the immigrants more so than
the actual act of immigrating itself
it's race and class as well as
nationality but you can't separate and
say it's just one or the other and
obviously race is a factor class is
connected with that as well when you
think about the Melania Trump situation
and it's absolutely pathetic what is
going on not only with Donald Trump and
Kellyanne Conway and Sean Spicer and
their non-existent terror attacks but
also with just the the layers upon
layers of nonsense that are surrounding
this on Fox News today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription in too I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the david pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS